We wanted flying cars instead of,
we got 140 characters with these words.
Peter Thiel,
the famous Silicon Valley investor who
we've talked about before,
joins the legions of people.
You consider that innovation in the past
few years has slowed down somewhat,
although most of the time of great
revolutionary inventions seems to have
been left behind.
Who else could have done it?
Start Trek,
Christy.
So competent.
Okay.
Things on that.
Yes.
Example,
if this slowdown can be found in the
automobile industry,
an industry that has been pretty static
for decades,
yes,
cars nowadays are better than 10 to 20
years ago,
that's for sure,
but they are basically the same and they
launch any work in the same way.
In fact,
there is nothing substantial that you
can do with a car today that you
couldn't do 20 or 30 years ago,
and of course cars still don't fly.
Maybe we present the top 95 you on,
you being,
Huh?
Sierra Alpha.
Bravo.
I'm Wendy was talking about a simple
industry here,
but one of the biggest industries in the
world.
However,
I do,
hold on a second here because everything
suggests that finally,
we are on the verge of a great
revolution in the realm of cars or trans
formation that many experts have
compared to the one in the early 20th
century that was engineered by Henry
Ford where he began to use assembly
lines to mass produce cars.
Wow.
Make this new revolution seems to have
two key features,
the electric car and the autonomous car.
And here we have an unquestionable star,
a company that isn't managed to start
changing things and knows how to win the
admiration of the many people who see us
as an example of a new era that is about
to begin.
We are of course talking about Tesla.
The company have electric cars that has
managed to dazzle investors as well as
governments.
And that in this video we are going to
see you what kind of challenges Tesla is
going to face in the coming years.
So let's dive in.
Okay.
History of wine and roses.
That's
what is a very young company.
It was born in 2003 with the mission of
producing an electric car capable of
competing and defeating combustion
engines.
Since then,
it has managed to basically put on the
market for models,
the Tesla roadster,
the model s,
the model x hands,
the newcomer,
the model three seems to be around the
few rights.
Well,
despite this,
in 2010 the company went public and you
know what happens?
Well,
Tesla,
it's become one of the markets stars in
these years.
The price of their shares has multiplied
by 18 yes.
Just like that.
In 2010 if you had invested $1,000
in Teslas shares today,
you would have $18,000
a pretty amazing investments.
All this growth has led tesla to fight
for first place among the most valuable
companies in the United States.
Yes.
Time of publishing this video,
if you want to buy us well,
prepare your wallet because Tesla is
worth more than $50 billion.
This is more than the value of forward,
by the way,
Amazon not that far off.
General Motors.
Just have a look at this chart from
business insight.
Yeah.
You think not bad.
Right.
This is especially the case.
If we take into account that it is a
company that is barely 14 years old and
there's,
well,
honestly doesn't sell that many cars.
Generally
it sells 10 million cars each year and
Ford exceeds 6 million,
but in 2016 Tesla managed to sell just
76,000
cars.
All right.
Okay.
Many of you are probably thinking right
now,
well,
come on Tesla.
They already sell luxury cars and yes,
that is true,
but it's still just 76,000
cars,
which is three times less than Paul is.
What explains why General Motors sales
in 2016 we're almost $170 billion while
tesla remains well below to just 10
billion.
Yeah.
Dollars.
Do you know think that what is happening
is Tesla has very high margins and is
earning a lot of money.
Not at all.
In fact,
in fact,
since the company was founded,
it is not ends money in any single.
Yeah.
Sorry.
This point you're probably wondering,
well,
why then is it worth so much money on
the stock market?
Why has it been so successful there and
why indeed is this company so famous?
Wow.
We all answer to that is that the
company has a lot to do with a
revolution that's happening in the
industry that we commented on before
hand.
That's the introduction of electric and
autonomous vehicles.
Perfect.
For example,
in 2016 there were more than 2 million
electric cars on the road.
60% is more than in the previous.
Yeah.
That is to say,
we are talking about markets that are
growing incredibly quickly.
Further technological advances have cut
the price of this type of car.
The forecast by Bloomberg new energy
finance said that electric cars would
become cheaper than conventional cars
without government subsidies between
2025 and 2030 and is on the other hand,
in as many countries,
including China itself on betting on
this technology as a way to reduce air
pollution in cities tend to also as a
way to reduce their dependence on
foreign oil.
It's not often that environment and
national security.
It comes together in such a combination,
but here we are.
Does that today.
Tesla is the great reference points in
this new industry.
Many investors understand this and
therefore value the future of the
company highly.
The company's own forecasts falling at
the same line and expects that
production will increase from 100,000
cars in 2017 to 500,000
in 2020 and more than a million by 2022
two
no,
he seems like we're talking about the
apple of the automotive sector.
Right?
Well,
just wait a minute because not
everything that surrounds Tesla is quite
so great.
Eight
rusher of money,
Tesla,
they have a problem,
a very serious problem indeed.
Kassala in machine for burning money.
Yes,
you heard me correctly today,
the business is not profitable than the
company loses money every day,
but not only that,
it also has to make a lot of investments
in order to compete.
For example,
its factories need pumping with loads
and loads of money.
We look at the money that comes in and
out of the cash box at Tesla as we
already did with Amazon.
We can say that from 2010 when it went
public,
the company has it swallowed absolutely
everything that is ends.
It is the money from the car sales as
well is about $10 billion more.
Yeah,
and the truth is that 2017 is not
exactly Tesla's best year.
In the first nine months of 2017 it's
swallowed about 4 billion.
Yes,
really $4 billion in nine months and not
only that,
but at the same time it's non financial
debt.
For example,
suppliers that have not been paid has
absolutely skyrocketed.
For this reason,
lights are beginning to flash red at the
company.
Consider this graph.
Yup.
In the last few months,
Tesla has lost $60 million every single
day.
Money of course,
but it's had to cover with debt,
but it doesn't stop that audits all
testing or is also having many problems
with its latest model constantly
reveals.
It just made 260 model three cars due to
production bottlenecks.
It also has quality problems and has
dismissed stuff,
which by the way is a little bit weird
when they seem to need to be making a
lot more cars rather than less.
So do you want to see the car
[inaudible] and
so now you might be thinking,
well surely there's got to be the worst
of it.
Right?
Well just wait a minute because the
worst of it is that the competition is
moving really,
really quickly.
Okay.
Thousand and 16 the [inaudible] and
group sold more electric cars than Tesla
and pretty much all big companies are
already working on electric vehicles and
autonomous cars.
I business by the way,
which companies such as apple,
Google and uber are also getting into.
And that's some pretty serious
competition.
So yeah,
Tesla is not,
the only player at this
game
is that almost all of its rivals is
actually earned money and their research
budgets at least as big as those at
Tesla
dining
lyric.
Steel's Tesla's thunder with heavy duty
electric truck.
So at this point you might be thinking
about what happens with Nokia and
blackberry when apple stood out from all
the major companies with the iphone.
So now I ask you,
do you think we could compare Tesla with
apple?
Well,
I do not believe that the answer is
easy,
but I do believe there are at least a
couple of differences that we do have to
take into account.
First.
Apple was always worried about earning
money with the iphone and seconds that
product with something really,
really disruptive.
So much so there's even the competition
predicted its failure.
What Steve Ballmer,
the then CEO of Microsoft said $500
I said,
that is the most expensive phone in the
world and it doesn't appeal to business
customers because it doesn't have a
keyboard,
which makes it not a very good email
machine.
Right now we're selling millions and
millions and millions of phones a year.
Apple is selling zero phones.
A year is six months.
Let's see how the competition goes.
Steve Vollmer,
former CEO of Microsoft
$500 I like our strategy.
I like it a lot.
As we have seen tesla does not have
money or have any particularly
surprising features.
However,
it has to be said.
Is this,
making your company on money has not
been the most motivating element for its
CEO.
The well noon,
Elon Musk
mosque,
the vision,
yeah,
sorry.
A genius ahead of his time.
These are many opinions about Elon Musk
and entrepreneur who has become a
billionaire from his venture.
Honest,
these are businesses that have never
worried about money with the exception
of paypal,
Tesla,
I bloop,
space x,
anything which Elon Musk is involved
with sounds like science fiction and
seems to have an infinite budget.
If something is clear,
it is that with his ideas.
Elon musk is influencing us in how we
see and to build our future.
Okay.
This does not mean that the future is
already written.
Tesla has done very useful work by
opening the market for electric cars and
showing that people
may like them.
Another issue is whether it can earn a
lot of money when it reaches its final
goal.
I won't bet on Tesla.
As an investor,
I think it will be very difficult to
survive.
Andres [inaudible] fund manager,
analyst coboss a m
[inaudible]
the opportunity.
Yeah.
Does everything we've seen,
I mean the Tesla is a company doomed to
failure?
No,
of course not.
Saying such a thing.
It's certainly not our intention and
among other things,
because the future is blank definition
on set and as big as Tesla also has many
competitive advantages.
For example,
today it has an obvious technological
advantage.
It is a leader in the development and
the manufacturing of batteries,
which are the key to any electric car
and very important for growth rate.
Yeah.
Then there is also China,
China,
China.
Do you know who the biggest market for
electric causes?
Well,
you might have guessed it from that last
comment.
It is indeed China in this country.
More electric cars are sold each year.
Then on the rest of the planet combines
and it's government has clearly opted
for this technology.
Well,
Tesla is now negotiating the
installation of a big factory in
Shanghai with rather preferential
conditions and you know was it seems
that negotiations with the Chinese
governments are going in the right
direction anyway,
I knew the future.
Well let us know what happens,
but what is clear is that Tesla has been
a turning points for the automotive
industry,
but that is also a fun facing many
risks.
The last one for example,
comes from Washington.
Yeah,
he
is that the fiscal reform of the
Republican Party is going to finish
public aid for the purchase of electric
cars.
Well,
we will see how that matter runs,
but when Hong Kong did something like
that,
tesla sales fell markedly.
Anyway,
now it's your turn.
Do you think Tesla will be successful
and will become the great car company of
the future?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope that you enjoyed this video and
please hit that like button if you did.
Also,
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
Who else could have done this?
Do some company okay for those things.